one of the things that attracted me to
the department was the willingness of
the faculty to help out with students
aspirations and their interests and
whether they end up in academia or
industry and maybe your entrepreneurship
and the faculty have a lot of advice to
provide for that so great to see the
diversity of students even in just
within a department we're all sitting in
the same classes we're all studying the
same thing but ultimately we all want to
do something different with what we
learn so I I'm just excited to see where
my fellow classmates are in a few years
the opportunity to study independently
was a great experience for me here in
the Department of statistics and data
science I reached out this is a
sophomore year I reached out to a
professor and asked is there something I
can work on without very much experience
with hands-on data analysis and so I was
given a data set from the open learning
initiative and I was asked to maybe try
to figure out what led to a success in a
student's a final exam grad school is
definitely the next step for me luckily
I feel that my experience here in
Carnegie Mellon put me in a good
position to pursue that so I'm very
excited for that